yeah I was a magician and I made in
those days the fortune sometimes while
in high school of twenty dollars
twenty-five dollars a knife at a church
or a company celebration or something
yeah I was very good i had some good
teachers and I bought I i was able to
lend my school teacher parents eight
hundred dollars as the down payment on a
new car when i was in 10th grade
I did some apparatus magic I did some I
have a genius rope routine that I do
taught to me by a genius magician at 15
i won a trophy at an International
Brotherhood of magicians convention
beating out in the same category the
president of the Society of American
magician which allowed my hometown paper
the lincoln journal and star to do the
headline with three pictures of me and
my bow tie and my rope and my sister
young Lincoln Sharpie best magicians
group head that just perfectly fit
there was a link between Carson and me
and magic because we sometimes I would
said Johnny teach me to do a double left
where the deck I could never master it
and he would come back to my dressing
room after we taped and his show and
demonstrate and one night he had me to
dinner at his house the thing his staff
couldn't believe since he didn't really
do stuff like that and he was producing
lit cigarettes when I arrived showing me
how and then we smelled something and
looking down there was almost by then a
quarter-sized blackburn spreading on the
brand new o busan carpet that his wife
had bought two days early so there was a
bit of tension at dinner